[Music]
the work of the ICN cartel working group
matters to you and here's why in 2019
ICN produced two brand new cartel
working group products just for you the
paramount importance of leniency
programs in the fight against cartels is
widely recognized our first product will
help your agency clean efficiency by
boosting your leniency program our ICN
Lab elaborated good practices for
incentivizing leniency applications to
help ease the burden of leniency
applicants from paying damages to limit
discoverability of leniency submissions
in damages actions to protect
individuals cooperating and allene E&C
from punishment and to enhance
cooperation between competition agencies
and other regulators our second product
addresses the concerns of the ICN
antitrust community about cartel victims
the cartel working group co-chairs
instructed an international team of
experts to explore and present to you
the most recent developments in private
anti cartel enforcement this can be
found in the new chapter of the anti
cartel enforcement manual on the
development of private enforcement of
competition law in ICN jurisdictions
finally as we all know efficient anti
cartel enforcement requires constant
learning and easy exchange of knowledge
so as in previous years stay tuned for
the new cartel working group webinars on
leaning secret practices and lessons
learned
private damages claims detecting and
assessing bidding cartels
information sharing and tacit collusion
and finally the use of presumptions in
cartel investigations
visit the icing website to find out more
about our latest work plan various work
products and our other awesome
activities
[Music]
[Applause]